saskia jones and jack merritt were
extremely bright and talented young
people
and through the evil actions of the
attacker their lives were tragically cut
short
on behalf of the metropolitan police and
counter-terrorism policing
i offer my deepest condolences to the
families of jack and saskia
and to their many friends to the
survivors of this shocking attack who
suffered the most appalling injuries
and to all those who've been traumatized
i must highlight and praise the bravery
of everyone involved in responding to
the attack
who put themselves in grave danger
as the coroner said in his summary of
the evidence this is a case in which
lives were saved by the emergency
response
i would also like to thank the coroner
and the jury for their careful
examination
of the circumstances surrounding the
attack and thank the investigation team
from london's counter-terrorism command
led by dci dan brown for their
painstaking work in supporting the
coroner
at the time the attacker was released
from prison there was a multi-agency
system in place to manage violent
offenders in the community
and together with our partners we are
significantly strengthening how
terrorist offenders
are managed within that system
over the past 20 years we have worked to
ensure that increasing numbers of
individuals who pose a
threat of serious harm are both
identified and imprisoned
before they can carry out terrorist
attacks but in recent years
as some of these individuals reached the
end of their sentences
we've realized that the way in which
terrorist offenders were managed
could be improved and we had identified
this and were making changes before the
attack took place
but the terrible events on the 29th of
november 2019
have only served to ensure that we've
redoubled our efforts
and since then the government has
changed the law
the ministry of justice has strengthened
prison and probation services
and we in policing have developed a far
stronger national offender management
model
but these changes can never provide a
100 guarantee
but they will in my opinion better
protect the public
from terrorist offenders
the coroner heard that this work was a
wholly new initiative devised by
counter-terrorism policing
it's one that's not been seen anywhere
in the world
but that we are making these changes
after this attack will i suspect be of
little or no comfort
to jack and saskia's family the fact
that as the jury determined there were
admissions or failures in the management
of the attacker
and in the sharing of information and
guidance by the agencies responsible
is simply unacceptable and i'm so deeply
sorry we weren't better than this in
november 2019.
but even with the new changes in place
it remains true that managing the risk
posed by terrorist offenders
is an incredibly challenging job for all
of the agencies involved
the stark reality is that we can never
guarantee that we will stop every attack
but i promise
we will do absolutely everything we can
to try
the jury has today concluded that jack
and sasuke were unlawfully killed and
this reflects the fact that whilst we
along with our partners must improve
the ultimate responsibility for this
barbaric act lies with the attacker
he deceived and betrayed almost everyone
he spoke to he lied
he alone chose to attack and murder some
of the very people who were trying to
help him
help him have the opportunity to live a
better life
which brings me back to jack and saskia
they have both chosen to do
something good with their lives to make
tremendously positive contributions to
our society
and it is precisely our precious society
and the incredibly humane and beautiful
people in it
like jack and saskia the terrorists want
to destroy
but as i've said we'll never cease
trying to stop them and collectively
all of us will stop that happening by
standing together against the evil
of terrorism and its perverse ideologies
and i promise those of us who work in
counter-terrorism will constantly seek
to be the best we possibly can
but the public the incredibly brave
public who helped us on the 29th of
november 2019
well i know the public will help us
again